All is quiet at the facility where SCP-1027
floats in its containment chamber.
The SCP does not seem to react as a guard
opens the door to its room.
The agent gropes for the light switch; he
is new to SCP Foundation, and this is his
first night working on his own.
Harsh fluorescent light fills the room.
The guard lets out a yelp when he sees SCP-1027
for the first time.
Unable to control his curiosity, the guard
approaches the containment chamber.
SCP-1027 looks like a human nervous system
that has been extracted from its body.
The brain, eyes, and connective nerves are
all exposed as if some mad doctor perfectly
dissected a human.
SCP-1027 does not move.
Gross, the guard thinks as he taps on the
glass casing with his rifle.
He jumps back slightly in surprise.
It seemed as if the eyeballs had twitched
slightly to look at him.
“So creepy,” the guard says out loud.
He turns around to exit the room.
As he approaches the door, the lights flicker.
He begins to walk a little quicker.
Suddenly the lights go out completely, plunging
the room into darkness.
A moment later, the hum of the fluorescents
resumes as the lights come back to life.
The guard slowly pivots to look at the containment
chamber.
SCP-1027 still floats motionless in its saline
solution.
The guard sighs and chuckles to himself for
getting spooked.
He turns and walks out of the room, closing
the door behind him.
He makes it a few steps down the hallway before
stopping.
The guard smacks his forehead with the palm
of his hand.
“I forgot to turn off the damn light,”
he says.
He heads back to the room SCP-1027 is contained
in.
He reaches his hand out to grab the doorknob.
It is warm to the touch.
The guard turns it and pushes the door open.
A scream gets caught in his throat and only
a slight wheeze escapes his lungs.
Standing in front of him is SCP-1027.
The nervous system seems to pulsate as it
reaches its arms out towards the guard who
is paralyzed with fear.
The guard feels a slight twinge in his ear
as a series of nerves enter his auditory canal.
Then he hears a voice inside of his head.
It’s his own voice, and it’s telling him
to escape his body.
The next morning SCP agents and scientists
return to the site for another day’s work.
One scientist is surprised to find the door
to SCP-1027’s room wide open.
He steps in and looks around.
SCP-1027 floats motionless inside of its saline
containment chamber.
The scientist shrugs, turns off the light,
and closes the door.
Later that day a feeding team enters SCP-1027’s
room pushing a cart with the brain of a cow
on top of it.
The three members of the group are wearing
level-4 bio-protective equipment.
They enter the room and secure the door behind
them.
One of the men walks over to the containment
chamber and pushes a few buttons.
As the liquid in the tube slowly begins to
drain, SCP-1027 drops down into a laying position
on the examination table below it.
When the water is completely gone, the glass
tube hisses open.
A moment later SCP-1027 sits up.
It looks about the room with its exposed eyeballs.
Its nerves wriggle like tiny worms as they
sense the world around them.
SCP-1027 rotates its body so it’s sitting
with its legs over the side of the table.
The feeding team tries to remain calm, but
seeing a nervous system move without an actual
body is a bit disconcerting to say the least.
Researchers found that SCP-1027 was able to
survive without the protective casing of muscles
and skin because each nerve cell is surrounded
by myelin sheathing 300 times thicker than
that of normal human cells.
The SCP slowly slides off the table and proceeds
towards the cow brain that has been placed
in the middle of the room.
The feeding team backs as far away from the
SCP as possible until their bodies are pressed
up against the wall.
SCP researchers told them that the containment
suits would protect them from 1027, but these
same researchers have been wrong before.
SCP-1027 stands next to the cow brain and
looks down at it.
Normally at this point, SCP-1027 would extend
its nerves and wrap them around the bovine
brain.
There would be a slight pulsing and the brain
would begin to denature.
It is still unclear if SCP-1027 consumes the
actual brain matter or just feeds on the residual
chemical energy that resides in the tissue.
The feeding team carries out this procedure
once a week, which seems to keep SCP-1027
happy.
But this time, SCP-1027 just stares at the
brain as if it is contemplating whether it
is worth eating.
It is almost as if SCP-1027 isn’t hungry.
As if it has already eaten.
But the team knows that’s crazy as they
are the only ones who feed this SCP, and it
has been exactly a week since its previous
meal.
The feeding team turns their heads to look
at one another through the clear face shields
in their suits.
One of the men shrugs as they all turn back
to watch what SCP-1027 does next.
The SCP lifts its head so that its eyes are
looking straight at the feeding team.
One of the members reaches behind him searching
for the doorknob.
Then, SCP-1027 slowly turns around and walks
back towards the table.
It lays down and goes still.
“Someone needs to lock it back in its containment
chamber,” one of the men says.
“That’s Jerry’s job,” responds another
as he pushes the man next to him towards where
SCP-1027 is laying.
“Alright, fine, I’ll do it.
But if that thing eats me and turns me into
an SCP, you two will be the first people I
go after.”
Jerry walks slowly towards the containment
chamber.
He stretches his arm as far as it will go
to keep as much distance as possible between
his body and SCP-1027.
Jerry pushes a big red button and the glass
tube hisses close.
The containment chamber fills with saline
water and SCP-1027 is once again suspended
in the liquid-filled tube.
The research team grabs the cart with the
cow brain on it and rushes out of the room,
slamming the door behind them.
They inform the head of the facility of the
odd behavior SCP-1027 had exhibited.
But he is a busy man and shrugs it off as
just an anomaly.
“It’ll eat when it’s hungry enough.
Give it a week and then try again,” the
facility commander tells the men.
The feeding team walks silently down the hall
to the decontamination room where they will
take off their suits and shower as a precaution
to prevent the spread of any foreign agents.
The peculiar behavior of SCP-1027 lingers
in their minds.
They enter the room and begin to joke with
one another to ease their nerves.
This makes them feel better.
It is silly to worry about SCP-1027 now that
it is safely contained in its chamber once
again.
They turn the shower heads on and steam slowly
fills the room.
“I might call out sick next week, just to
be safe.
That SCP is going to be really hungry after
missing its meal this week and I don’t want
to become a snack,” one of the men says
as he scrubs his body.
“Yeah, that’s not a bad idea,” responds
Jerry.
“Who knows what that creepy thing will do
if it ever gets out of its containment chamber.
Maybe it’ll eat our brains.
Although there wouldn’t be much to eat in
your case Bob,” he says pointing to his
teammate.
The whole team laughs as the room continues
to fill with steam.
Jerry’s smile slowly fades as he feels something
tickle his ear.
He uses his hand to brush whatever it was
away.
But the sensation comes back.
Jerry washes the soap from his face and turns
around; all he can see is steam.
“Hey you guys, stop messing around,” Jerry
yells.
“What are you talking about Jerry?”
one of the other members of the team asks.
Jerry sees the steam move directly in front
of him.
He rubs his eyes to help him focus through
the moisture.
When he takes his hands away an instance of
SCP-1027 is standing directly in front of
him.
He is staring straight into the eyeballs of
the nervous system of the guard who had entered
SCP-1027’s room the previous night.
“What the—” but before Jerry can finish
his sentence the instance of SCP-1027 shoves
its nerves down Jerry’s throat silencing
his voice.
It then sticks the nerves of its hand into
Jerry’s ear.
The SCP-1027 instance feels around in Jerry’s
head until it locates the part of the brain
it is looking for and connects to it.
Jerry’s brain is flooded with dopamine and
chemical signals are transferred from the
SCP-1027 instance directly into its victim’s
brain.
Jerry’s nervous system now wants to break
free of the flesh casing that contains it.
“Jerry, are you okay over there?” asks
Bob.
“You’ve gone kinda quiet.”
But there is no response.
Jerry’s nervous system moves his body towards
one of the shower knobs and turns the hot
water on full blast.
It’s hoping that if the water is hot enough
it will scald the skin and muscle tissue making
it easier to remove from the body.
“Jerry?”
the other team member says.
Suddenly the steam shifts and the SCP-1027
instance is standing in the middle of the
shower room.
The remaining members of the feeding team
scream in horror.
They try to escape but slip on the wet shower
floor.
SCP-1027 slowly approaches them with its nerves
outstretched.
The echoing shouts from the feeding team are
muffled as a series of nerves enter their
bodies.
The day continues at the SCP site as if everything
was normal.
Agents are debriefed on previous missions,
scientists experiment on different SCPs, and
administrators meet to plan the next acquisition.
The sun begins to set and people start to
leave for the day.
All is quiet that night as a new security
guard makes his rounds.
The guard that the administrator of the facility
had just hired disappeared without a trace
the night before.
His disappearance was chalked up to nerves
and being too scared to return to work.
The new guard checks each room to make sure
everything is secure.
He approaches the room that contains SCP-1027.
He opens the door, flicks on the light, and
looks at the SCP floating in its containment
tube.
“Gross,” the guard says out loud.
He flicks off the light and continues his
rounds.
Near the far part of the hallway the door
to the decontamination room is slightly ajar.
The guard approaches and pushes it open with
his nightstick.
He takes one step into the darkness and feels
the wall for the light switch.
He turns the lights on.
There is nothing there but a wet floor.
The guard shrugs and turns off the lights.
He walks through the doorway.
As he steps back into the hallway, he is greeted
by four instances of SCP-1027.
The guard opens his mouth to scream as the
nervous systems reach out their tendrils and
plunge them into his ears, nose, and mouth.
Now watch “SCP-1548 - The Star, the Hateful
(SCP Animation).”
Or check out “SCP-001 - The Children - Ouroboros
Cycle (SCP Animation).”